are we live you live
what's up yeah you look better buddy
i feel a lot better you're literally
been exactly 15 days
since i was exposed i would imagine at
least 15
the minimum is 15 i would imagine maybe
we got exposed
friday because you guys got started
showing symptoms on sunday so
you know 15 16 17 18 days
it's a weird thing and you've been in
the thick of it all
15 days i i sure have i've been pacing
my [ __ ] floors
with nowhere to go i don't know what's
worse feeling like your lungs are a
glass
made of glass or just the sheer boredom
of not going anywhere and maybe even
worse is not having any taste
or smell that sucks because food's not
coming to your rescue no you don't care
about food now you
and then i started getting some taste
back but it was the wrong kind like i
tried to
sniff some wine and some coffee i almost
threw up
really yeah i almost threw up i was like
oh then i took some zinc on an empty
stomach that was good when you got some
expensive zinc
that you take you know from a dropper
o'brien
albright threw up super hard
there's nothing worse i did that i
learned the hard way too because yeah
my doctor was like take zing to get your
taste back soon and he was right
so i was popping all his zinc but i was
drawing an empty stomach and i was like
oh man i feel
nauseous and i text yo hey man i haven't
had any symptoms but since she told me
to take zinc
i'm starting to feel nauseous and he's
like are you taking my empty stomach i
go yeah he goes
well figure it out dude that's the only
thing you've done
dude
inside so i went i did a double like i
did a shoot i was like
and then i ran in and just shouted into
the bowl
i'll tell you what fun is uh you know i
had to quarantine so i was away from the
kiddos so my girl had to hold down the
fort with the kid i was
two kids by the way six months and a
four-year-old so she's got to
go into bed and drive tiger to school
and then i get better i'm like cool i
can help
and then she goes cool story walking the
baby downstairs
misses a step whoops her ankle franco
goes oh
you're supposed to go that way i'm gonna
go this way oh god
damn it the size of a hippopotamus now
it's like this
that's so she can't help with the kids
so now i got better
she's in bed and i gotta take care of
the kiddos dad duty
here's here's what i would do
differently if i could have i would have
gotten right on an inhalable steroid the
minute i started getting a cough
and i would have gone the
hydrochloroquine which seemed to really
work for you
and and and you know there's a lot of
evidence
in the first 36 hours for anybody who
has this that
hydrochloroquine and your your proof of
it
really does help really does help you
know i i'll i'll say that you know
you know you got it stevie got it your
girl got it i got it we've got some
other friends who have had it
and it's what's weird about is it
affected everybody different
obviously you know why we had symptoms
early just
mild symptoms early and then it went
away after three days and i was super
fortunate
you've had it's been let's be honest
it's been a struggle for 15 days
another friend of ours you know for i'd
say
four nights it was really intense for
him and then it got better
and it's just it affects everybody
different you know we do got to be safe
and thank god everyone who got it is
okay now and
um i'll tell you what's fun though too
is uh
you know you wanna you wanna show up uh
naked to go back to work to go back to
studio which is why we're not in studio
this week
so i took two tests last week i keep
calling like where's my results my
results
and they go oh sorry buddy that that
swab that we stuck
balls deep up into your nose well we
lost the results
so we need you coming back in that's a
good time
that's a good time hey thanks a lot
thanks let's get let's get back up in my
nose deep
ah dude yeah i'm going to take i'm going
to take a swab um
in a couple days you should do it you
should wednesday be
yeah i will because that's technically
when
100 i will have had symptoms by
wednesday it'll be symptoms for 15 days
so
that's yeah and then i'll be you should
wednesday so you get your results back
to friday i'm doing it today
i mean i could like i did last week
because i would have you know tested
negative most likely so
i'll do it today to get my results back
on wednesday but
glad to put it is your taste and smell
back
yeah for the most part i mean still a
little still a little
by probably probably like 80 80 percent
you know
i was talking to stevie blue eyes too
like you know and this isn't
um you know i'm not saying that you guys
shouldn't be worried about cover or
anything like that but
uh honestly health-wise i feel better
than before when i got sick
i feel if i was 100 before i feel 110
percent right my energy is through the
roof
i'm sleeping better um
i don't know i'm eating pizza every day
well
one thing i've never taken for granted
is my health
ever ever and uh when you're sick with
this thing
and down and walking around with nothing
to do you can't go anywhere
yeah you you wonder you really really
really
think about people who have debilitating
illnesses
always feel that way or if you're
thinking about you know if
someone was old in your family they got
it because of our dumb ass you know you
gotta worry about something like that
if you're older you have underlying
conditions or let's say you were
you know you're dating some fat girl you
know it'd be a problem
well here's the other thing here's the
problem you know the biggest issue to me
is
uh we still are left with having to move
forward with the economy
yeah and having to move forward with our
lives and and
the i unfortunately most of us i
certainly can't
wait for a vaccine i can't and and i
don't think most of us can
and the people that can afford to might
be people who
have jobs that are you know
i don't want to pick on the media but
you know a lot of media a lot of
academics have jobs
not to worry about whereas most of us
who work and have to come up
have to create a business and keep a
business going you know i don't have
that luxury man i i really don't
we're not
he's very cautiously optimistic about
2021.
okay what if it's 2022. i i can't afford
it so
a lot of us in this country are elected
these celebrities get on their
on the tweet and go let's just wait till
vaccine and we don't need kids in school
it's like hold up dude
you made captain america nine you're
you're fine yeah
the rest i need my kid russell world is
suffering dude and i i i need my kids
back in school
i need my kids dude you want to talk
about a disadvantage you know
california just said they're good the
rest of the years can be online and
they've done research and it shows
kids online it's a real detriment to
their to their learning and it's not
good
well i'm i'm in the process of trying to
help with creating
a homeschooling environment with uh
people a lot of different kids from the
neighborhood because
i don't think it's i don't think it's
good for these children to be isolated
certainly not for my children
i totally disagree 100
with the idea that children have to stay
home well that's just i think people
the private schools are going back
private schools like my son's been in
school for
three weeks now wow because private's
different than the public schools right
public or you're going to be out for
quite some time because remember too a
lot of the a lot of
the other issues they have is a lot of
teachers don't feel safe going back
because a lot of those teachers are
older
but yeah a lot of them are collecting on
employment too bro so
making more money not teaching your kid
it's a tough place for teachers to be if
they're older that's for damn sure
and some peaches are just afraid i don't
blame them a lot of people are just
afraid man
i get it you might you know a lot of
people are just afraid and i understand
i i'm not i'm not i can't i can't really
that's the problem and so frustrating i
can't really criticize people
for being afraid either you know some
people are just cautious and
and very worried about catching this
[ __ ] fact i have friends who are
yeah well [ __ ] dude i'll be you know
i've been ranting raven about i'm a
statistic guy and all this stuff and
look at the
data and i i do stick by that for the
majority if you get covered you're going
to be just fine
and everyone that i know or associate
with who's got this virus
is fine but you know last week dude when
you were getting worse
i i called rogan i'm like dude we got to
figure something out with count he's not
getting better dude i was
i couldn't sleep i was worried too i was
worried yeah you know
around about your age but you're not
young you know and you're
it's just like [ __ ] dude it's like it's
just me yeah rogan rogan's called me
every day you've called me every day a
lot of my friends have called me every
day
and i i i'll be honest i was very i was
very happy to come out of it the other
side
i talked to like you know i got a lot of
friends that are doctors and it was so
interesting
to talk to all of them i talked to four
doctors and all of them were like
all of them basically said look you
can't there's not much to do
however the inhalable steroid for my
cough game changer
[ __ ] game that's what they do in
taiwan
so they live on top of each other yeah
and they've had very very few deaths so
what they do right away is they get them
on a nebulizer they get them on a very
basic steroid uh very cheap uh
an inhalable steroid yeah and it's it's
a game changer man
so because it's an inflammatory disease
and what what
uh what the [ __ ] inhaler does is it
brings your
inflammation down but look man yeah it's
humbling it's [ __ ] humbling it was a
little scary
yeah i was scared for you you know yeah
but well i said crazier [ __ ] happens
right it's like my doctor said hey
don't take this thing lightly i got a
marathon runner who's in his 30s
and he just died and then i talked to a
woman who was very nice
and her cameraman uh died he was 55. so
there's a lot of [ __ ] you know it's it's
like anything else it's a [ __ ]
it's a weird weird virus yup i'm glad
everybody came out on the other end and
everybody's healthy now and
hopefully we'll be back in studio next
week and after it man because if i do
one more zoom podcast
i'm gonna take a monster bottle and
shove it all the way down my throat
i understand well i i think we shoot for
uh
being in studio friday i think that
might be if i if i come up with two
negative tests in a row whoa i like with
that i want to kiss your crooked teeth
yeah and if not we we do it next monday
yeah that would be appropriate
dude they want you though i've got my
master's degree
in everything pablo escobar and
everything um
whitey bulger i've bought literally and
i've read through
two books now on pablo escobar i got
this new whitey bulger one i'm attacking
now
that's got the who's who's a bigger
[ __ ] escobar
oh dude that's the bar
he keep crash planes no hold on hold
this is what i would make very
[ __ ] clear in narcos does a good job
but i'm re-watching narco season one and
two with pablo escobar i think it's the
greatest
tv of all time here's my issue with this
is
they they make you fall in love with
pablo escobar and how he's like giving
robin hood of the poor you got to
understand something in the in the
in the 80s and the early 90s when pablo
escobar was in the midst of his [ __ ]
you're talking about a straight-up
terrorist a terrorist
serial killer oh oh why because he
killed and this is just cops
400 cops a year every year he was in
business
400 cops a [ __ ] year dude and he's
also
when you talk about money-wise you're
talking about a guy worth when
when when you know he was killed or
most people including his friends and
family said he actually shot himself he
wasn't shot he shot himself when he's
about to get caught
that's the majority of people said he
shot himself but you're talking about a
guy who was
at the time we're 30 and this is in 1992
30 billion dollars 30 billion dollars
you make 640 million dollars a week
good [ __ ] god it's not good
what else is crazy like narcos i was
reading his son who's
you know he he was kind of going against
narcos he goes
when you watch narcos and you see like
when pablo's on the run with his family
and they show him these cool houses and
there's pools and his helicopters he
goes
that's the one thing they're so off on
that he goes we were not in nice places
we were in the [ __ ]
in these shanties and we were scared for
our lives
and he goes yeah and he goes and
everyone makes seem like my dad was this
loving father and all this stuff he goes
my dad didn't trust anybody when we
would go from place to place he'd
blindfold me and my
little sister and my wife because he
thought we were gonna snitch on him
and his mother yeah yeah wow just like
i'm not a real piece of piece of [ __ ]
yeah he
he would cheat at monopoly he cheated
everything he was just a
bad guy well you know when when they
when they caught him and they wanted to
extradite him to america
he his way of having the government
switch the rules
is by taking people hostages who were
government uh the children of the
governor of the elite
oh and then killing them and then
killing them and then if you didn't like
that he'd blow up
schools shopping centers he was a great
guy
and he blew up a [ __ ] airliner he
literally
blew up an airliner full of people and
do you know how he
got the bomb on the plane well he gave
it to a 17 year old
who thought he was recording two
gentlemen speaking he conned this
17 year old who just had a new baby girl
because he killed it and then killed his
wife yeah yep
killed the wife killed yep and then and
wanted to kill the baby too so
good guy he's a very very nice guy i
mean don't get me wrong
whitey bulger you know he never killed
anybody who wasn't in the business you
know that's the way the
the the irish mob worked but
you know [ __ ] pablo escobar you're
talking about a real
[ __ ] just a sociopath that's a true
social media
terrorist dude a straight-up [ __ ]
terrorist yeah well he he said he said
i'm gonna
i'm gonna get them to change the laws in
colombia
the extradition laws and if they don't
do it i'm gonna i'm gonna just
create so much havoc and bomb
the city centers until they do my
bidding yeah he got really
he hired a guy who's really good at
these these bombs these homemade bombs
and was blowing up buildings and
in public places and farmers markets and
you're talking about people
you know now they idolize them and
there's pablo escobar paintings
dude you're talking about a guy who
literally the
entire nation was terrified people would
stay in their houses dude
didn't you send me a thing about mexico
this year being the bloodiest
hold up dude we're talking about corona
we're talking about pablo esquire
right now in mexico june was their
bloodiest month
ever because of the cartel wars going on
there check this out
114 people died in under 24 hours
due to shooting from the cartel jesus
christ
can't there aren't there cameras where
they can see this stuff and track this
stuff
like the way the united states has i
mean what will it
they don't have the infrastructure do we
know why though because they had a new
president
came in two years ago and it's gotten
worse since he was there what happened
did he take their hands off approach
yeah they're they're well
what they're saying a lot of it is
because it's so ingrained it's so it's
not only is it in obviously the cartels
and it's part of their culture i'll hate
to say it but it's also ingrained in
their politics
one doesn't play without the other no
it's it's systemic it goes all the way
up to the federal level
oh dude it's so bad over there the
jalisco cartel and all those guys have
yeah they they're not working alone here
they've got
people in the federal military and
police foreign
everybody's on the take it's like my
friend said he goes you know when you
when you talk about cartel
what you're really saying is that it's
like you got a guy who's here and he's
like well my cousin works for that guy
my other brother works for them
everybody's involved in one way or
another well and not but also like
until you know el chapo when he got
caught
the one the only reason el chapo got
caught was because of americans
and until until you get the americans
and that's why
all these cartel guys whatever city
they're in colombia
mexico russia if americans get called
and you bring in our special forces
one thing about americans we do not
that's why all of them are terrified of
america
because not only gonna get you but we're
gonna actually
yeah that's gonna be bad but you know
that when
that mexico you know we took out that
jalisco or whatever the hell they're
called cartel
the americans helped out with that and
then now you know with el chapo's
sons trying to fight for power and it's
it's great it's not it's not safe dude
no no it's like a war going on it's
[ __ ] crazy man talk about
stress i'd be a little stressed oh my
god i can't imagine this let's tell my
girl can you imagine
pablo escobar just with his family on
the run but here's what's interesting is
his wife you know after pablo was killed
every cartel in colombia wanted to kill
her and her kids you know just to prove
a point
so they had to go into hiding and so i'm
like oh that poor lady blah blah blah
pan to [ __ ] five years ago her and
her son get arrested on drug trafficking
what yeah man they met back in the
[ __ ] business yeah they got they got
arrested but they couldn't
they didn't have enough evidence so they
held them for 15 months and let them go
back in the old family business and then
the doctor
i think that i think that people are
going to want to get high
your your biggest market is just to your
north you the only way
latin america gets out of this is by
legalizing drugs
yes it's the only [ __ ] way you mean
otherwise they they keep paying i'm
saying i'm saying
latin america keeps paying for our drug
habit with their blood and tears
and i and if i'm latin america if i'm
mexico if i'm
any of those countries i [ __ ]
legalize it i go
you guys keep doing the drugs you're
buying all the drugs so
let's legalize it we'll just [ __ ]
zone it
we'll tax it we'll organize it yeah you
know people
you guys can make your money get the
biggest do this and yeah
and then i'd have the federalists say
look everybody gets a take including
us if there's any violence though and
you start killing people you're gonna
have a problem so we're just gonna focus
on that
and otherwise otherwise let's zone it
let's cut it up
and then it's all free and then if
you're american come on down
i mean that's what i do yeah what's the
alternative how's it going otherwise
the real issue would be you need america
north north america
america to legalize drugs because then
there's no incentive
to do all this crazy [ __ ] and territory
and sneak it in and smuggle it in and
no you cut them out from the legs by
doing that you know
yeah that's all you can do that's all
you can do well because whatever we're
doing is not working here's the other
thing
in those cities where 114 people died in
24 hours
not only do they have to worry about
kobed which is hitting over there now so
you got
cartel coven you know they they have
they have
lockdowns after dark because of the
cartel shootings they're so bad they
have to stay inside their house
jesus everyone's yeah you know
you know we we cry about being
quarantined here in the states because
of covet and being with our loved ones
but
trust me could be a lot worse yeah you
can't even earn a living
you start a business good luck and they
come in and go we'll take this you know
what else you know what else is
yeah exactly what else is frustrating is
like mostly other countries besides
america because
we're americans just what we do what's
make makes this nation great and we
think for ourselves but
all these other countries went we have
to wear a mass we have to stay
quarantined
all right we're going to do that and
they did it and you're a lot you're
talking about most of europe's back to
normal
you know south america korea all
everyone's back
but americans but nah you know and we're
this you're we're one of these guys like
you start with masking you start taking
away our guns and take away our freedom
and then everyone's like okay dude cool
but
i'm telling you here we are and now
we're here and we have
americans don't follow rules well and
you're right i was not
i was not a good rule follower and i was
very critical i would have liked a
little consistency though
the problem with america is that we
weren't given any real [ __ ]
consistency
i was hearing three different stories
very difficult
and i'm still i'm still hearing the new
england journal of medicine comes out
without you and says masks actually
don't stop the spread
yeah there's a lot of stuff so i'm like
you know can somebody please
can we get a consensus here you know um
but but that's not going to happen yeah
it's not going to happen
i feel like in america it's gotten more
political now it's just
i don't know dude like i took my son uh
to this outdoor
mall the grove here in l.a and his it's
his favorite spot
dude don't go to the grove looks like
walking dead now everything's boarded up
there's like one or two shops everyone's
in mass there's not that many people
it makes me so depressed man my son goes
papa what happened
that i go to sickness i'm like and then
i would to get down there i took laurel
canyon and last time i
took laura canyon was get to the commie
store i got
super depressed thinking will that never
come
well those days of us hanging out the
comment store with our boys and
doing stand-up and hanging it just
popping over there
how excited i was to get there at 8 30
and see all my friends and
try new bits like are those are those
golden days over
like at the time do we realize that we
were in the golden age of
our comedy careers or is that just over
i think that's uh i think for now that's
over
you don't think it will it'll ever
bounce back i think when there's a
vaccine it will
but it's gonna be a long time yeah and
and i don't know when that's going to be
i mean uh
i i just don't i don't know will you i
don't know
here's the good news your lids do look
better but one eye is lower than the
other and you know this well
and you know and by the way this eye
just as hooded has ever been
as it's ever been maybe even more so at
the end of the day
the lid surgery not so much you know
let's be honest let's be honest still
got some circles under my eyes too
that hasn't gone away who knows why it
doesn't matter though it does look
better but the one eye
is more than the other well well here's
the thing i don't think it looks better
but that's okay too
and here's the thing uh it we we tried
and it didn't work out and sometimes
brandon in life things don't work out
and you might come out with one wonky
eye and maybe i don't
who knows at the end of the day now you
can still be
a sniper my my my um i have a
cousin who's a plastic surgeon and he
said to
his wife he said man i was looking at
his eyes
and and he casually said i don't know if
he's a candidate
he's like what do you mean he goes i
mean he would need a brow lift
otherwise it's going to not do it and i
remember she said that
and i dismissed it i just uh what does
that guy know he's only been doing it
for 50 years
what's he know and i just plunged ahead
so
it turns out that obri is let's i'm
gonna i'm gonna walk over now and i'm
gonna look at my eyes right now
yep don't see a goddamn difference
exactly
just a little bit more exactly the same
he really added a little hood to the top
well i like to give my eyes a real
beating and then get covered so
things have been good it's been a [ __ ]
month
yeah it's been tough dude it's been
tough brother did you watch
uh the fights on saturday i watched the
fights
on saturday why did it sound like the
fights went on for
20 hours because they did because they
did
um i was glad i i was glad that rose
namajunas won that fight
i think she's awesome i was glad that
um i i disagreed
with the max holloway decision i think
max
won that fight uh handed not handily but
fair and square i think it was three to
two
yep no no question and it was because
max
it was really interesting because max
was pressing the pace and he
he was moving forward if the last fight
he was always moving back because
um kept moving forward
and that changed um in this fight that
was weird
but uh listen man uh it is what it is
it is what it is i was very surprised
that max lost that what did you
think of uh well
i mean i don't know
how i i thought this i i i think that
mas vidal would
because he had i was talking about this
he had to suck from 194
to 70 in a very short period of time so
i knew his wind would be
a problem or that's what i was worried
about and i knew it would be usma never
has a wind problem
i don't know where he gets that cardio
from and he's a [ __ ]
grinder you know he just how are you
going to solve that problem it's that
john
fitch khabib it's even more than that
though baby because it's like
yeah you're striking you gotta worry
about two yeah you do
yes and it's like this incredible pace
and it's like you know we've seen khabib
get a little tired
we've never seen newsmen get tired even
against kobe covington and woodley
no edward so it's like and he's also
very smart keep in mind
he's strategic like he he does weird
[ __ ] to win
and i don't know how you solve that
problem
i i think the only guy who can give him
fritz is maybe a leon edwards could
could pose some problems for him even
though he did beat him but he's a better
fighter now but the other thing is
the only guy nope the only guy i think
that could
uh finish camaro usman
would be uh mazdal on a full camp do you
remember i don't care what anybody says
and i don't know what mozvah said in his
post fight but
a six day notice is a six [ __ ] day no
it's a nightmare
with travel with travel and everything
yeah travel
covet test you're you say you've been
getting ready but unless you have a
contract on paper and you know who
you're fighting
weeks out you're not in the same
grinding mode so
and he even said you know i think he
mentioned he got tired in the third
round after that you know it was tough
especially with loose men's style so
you know if you give moswell a full camp
he's really the only guy i can see
giving oozeman any trouble anytime soon
leon edwards he could pose some problems
but
outside that man i don't know i i still
even even even with my has a full camp
and his wind is amazing
i still don't know how you solve that
problem once he closes distance
and grabs onto your knee with that
little snatching single
or just clinches up with you and gets
you on the ground you're still
you're still in the same [ __ ] boat
still have the same problem think about
this mazel doll
and i think you know people don't
realize is how good his takedown defense
was
amazing amazing
stood up every time he's a [ __ ]
killer he's a killer
but you might see the same fight you
might see a
grind out again most likely um
yeah because because you know camaros
also
he he does throw he throws well he's
but he but he even admitted when you
know when he throw he was getting tagged
he was losing the
exchanges now all i'm saying is mazdale
has the cardio
go 25 minutes those exchanges in the
third fourth and fifth round even the
first and second he's to be more willing
to do it because he
doesn't have to reserve his tank so if
he can trade those in the third fourth
and fifth while this one might get a
little tired
you have more of a shot to finish him
because in that last fight he didn't
really have a shot in the fourth and
fifth it was just
more of a beat down that's 100 right
that's 100 right aldo and uh
i i love aldo and it's exactly what i
figured
because of all the mileage on aldo uh
you're just not for whatever reason with
fighting
uh when you've taken the kind of just
the just the wear and tear that aldo has
you're not going to be able to in the
fourth and fifth round
you're just not going to keep up with a
younger fresher
up and coming yon who is 27 years old
it's just different and and you could
see it the guy
on round four was jumping up and down
and ready to [ __ ] go
and and and that's what it's really
interesting with fighting and whatever
happens to your body aldo looked amazing
so muscular so [ __ ] great he was
[ __ ] great for those three rounds but
at the end of the day man i don't know
it's how long aldo's been doing
it dude yeah he's so and his striking
his ability to stand right there and
and and move his head and catch and
angles and and come back is just
astonishing
so hard to hit about yana 27 who's never
been in a real
high profile fight fight you're out of
faber thought jimmy rivera
doesn't have a crazy resume he went oh
you're good at striking
i'm not gonna go here's a line in the
sand here's a russian line in the sand a
rush
not moving back moving so if you want to
play this fist cuss in a phone booth
i'm game for that and i was like oh [ __ ]
he's the real deal
he's the real deal he's [ __ ] the real
deal i don't know who bt on right now
i mean i don't know who beats john i
don't know i'd like to see you know i
want to see him fight
what i want to see him fight cody
garbrandt
peter young cody garbrandt's a
[ __ ] fight it's a [ __ ]
fight because co
co cody's young and he's fresh too and
he's
we'll exchange
the hardest hitter in the division hands
down yes he hits hard
and he's going to stand there too so now
now now you realize you and jessica
andraj have the same haircut yeah
we had the same haircut we had the same
haircut
she's got an amazing jawline um
and she's an amazing fighter but yes we
do yes we do
she is a uh she's a she's a handsome
strong i i say this with respect she's a
she's got a strong presence very very
kind of
you know they're powerful wednesday and
and saturday this week too yes and i'm
very
excited about the caterer uh ing fight
do you see that video ebay thought that
when va fought barbosa it was incredible
he got stronger as the fight went on
lions dude that was [ __ ] hawaii
[ __ ] he's amazing [ __ ] he's great and
but cater is uh
i mean kate remember cater [ __ ] gave
zabit the watch for well hold on
if that fight was a main event for five
rounds he would have beaten the b
i mean i agree with you cater is a
[ __ ]
peter is as good as anybody in the 45
now his one two is
straight one two is it's it's second to
only conor mcgregor as far as
efficiency there's nobody
yeah he's he's gonna be he's he's a
nightmare for anybody
he's a knight don't be he's a guy who
could easily have the belt actually
oh yeah there's no question he's excited
that i have fights to watch wednesday
and something to do on saturday
that's my life who's fighting saturday
joey benavidez
yeah fighting uh figure
figure with the colored hair who else is
fine you missed it because i was talking
[ __ ] to you you missed my favorite
fighter now he's my new favorite fighter
i have a crush on him
wicked smart as well you missed the yuri
fighting the ozdamir you would pull over
dude
first of all i did see it he's first of
all
are you talking about are you talking
about mr kung fu
about the showman
the showman bodied up bodied up
first team all show pony dude first team
awesome
pony he's a show and and
and i was like i don't know what he's
doing right now he's talking
he's doing weird [ __ ] he's looking he'd
stop and look over in this direction and
then move back
and then
yeah i was hard the whole time well
i understand what i understand that's
your prerogative fighter
oh hard fighter hard fighter okay i got
a little scared man
here's my question now doing it wrong
ozimer is right number seven in the
world he's one of the best
there is does he get away with those
same tactics find a guy
like oh i don't know glover taxera or
gustafin
or you know some of these other killers
add tools let me say this very clearly
watch your vlogs dude i know we're not
in studio
you watch your [ __ ] mouth when you're
talking about my show pony yuri
now listen you're girl i'll come to your
house he's a [ __ ] spartan dude
get in your grill and i'll start from
turf i'll cover surfing turkey right now
oh
[ __ ] yeah bubba you know you don't have
lungs because you have the covered legs
i don't
have lungs that's true and i'll cough on
you now listen
listen if he tries that show boat [ __ ]
against if he tries that show [ __ ]
against every [ __ ] technician
against anthony smith against
against [ __ ] what's his name from
sweden uh why am i blanking on his name
right now go assistant
alexander gustafsson
he's gonna get both he's gonna pay he's
gonna pet
he's not ready for those guys let's not
get too excited
let's not get too [ __ ] excited that
he did a great job but you can't
you can't be doing you can't be doing
that stuff i think thiago santos might
have a
an issue with it if he doesn't if he
fights him and doesn't look at him
you're going to have problems with
thiago santos
you're going to have some problems yeah
so let's be careful with that
i love him i love him
my guess is by the way it might be how
he deals with nerves
it might be sometimes you showboat
because you're [ __ ] nervous
and it gets you in a zone and it [ __ ]
gets into the other guy's head
some guys don't get in they don't get
some guys though the veterans it doesn't
get into their head
you know they go oh that's cool oh you
know you should oh try that against
jon jones or dc let me know how that
worked for you no no no no no
no no no not against guys like that they
just
they watch you do all the stuff and then
they go come come
are you done are you done sweet body
check out dude
but here's the thing he's beat king mo
lawal he beat cb dolloway
you know he he's beat some tough dudes
and it
and that you know this is they offered
him a ufc contract a while
he knocked cb out didn't he correct well
he knocked
i mean top five hardest hitters in the
division he's charging dude
yeah he's got wins oh man
no no no no no barber it's called father
time
yes yes we do i have a little better
my hair is actually ozone looks very
handsome in a hat
in a cap i thought myself i thought
ostomy looks very handsome
i don't know what he's doing with his
face he's got his beard he's tall and
handsome
and then he takes his head off and he
looks like friar tuck you can't look
like fire talk
nightmare so we got to make a choice do
we shave our head completely it's a
problem
you have better hair than him i do have
better hair than me
thank you thank you hymns yep so yeah
where what what about rose namajunas
your thoughts on her performance and
where she goes from here rose is the
best in the world
when she when she's mentally into it
when she's when she's not or she's
somewhere else it doesn't feel like
fighting it's a nightmare for us so
she was still great though she was still
great against jessica andreas the first
fight
she pieced her up even more yeah she's
winning she had a check hook
amazing check hook that jab you know um
for me it's always it's it's rose versus
roses rose is ready to go she's the best
in the world
i think she can beat what weylie zang
you know even
even you know how good whaley is i do
think rose beats her if she's on that
night so
and wayley even said rose is her
toughest competition so
you're gonna get that next wow
wow yeah i think rose is [ __ ]
astonishing
uh she's she's my favorite she and yoni
and jinger are my favorite
uh female fighters to watch and by the
way i shouldn't even say that
i think they're so technically great i
love watching them fight period i like
them
i like watching them spread as much as
almost anybody else
male or female oh wow interesting that's
the code i just think tech
i don't know i just think technically
yeah yeah so sorry relax
relax relax i need you to take it down
much i think
would you rather watch rhodes with
jessica and stephen dc3
oh okay well in some ways i kind of
would because i like the
i like the fluidity of rose oh sure sure
sure did you like the fluidity of
max holloway brian i do like his fluid
he'll be talking
that's fine give me a little give me a
little pass
give me a little pass there yeah it was
exciting though
i've been watching a lot of weird [ __ ] i
watched an exhibition match between
jordan burroughs and uh [ __ ] um
uh uh ben askren
uh and jordan burroughs beat him 11
nothing like like it was nothing
and then i watched all these weird
things
you watch fighting and i watch i just
read books and watch narco [ __ ]
well i watch ballers i've watched every
series from ozarks to ballers to
everything so
i like ballers i'm new to that hopefully
the studios can open up soon so we get
new [ __ ]
i don't know man that's a big issue
isn't it
that hollywood is really really
panicking
because they just don't know how to do
this and i think netflix is running out
of content
and and well that's obvious if you just
zip through it
so i don't know man we are living in an
unprecedented times my friend
hey chin uh do you see some uh
breaking news that newsom locked down
the city again
no i got a i got a bunch of messages
that new sims locked in
la down again i haven't seen it i'll
check it out though
yeah let me know ain't nothing but your
regular what can you do
what kid is he locking down like trails
and
i hope not uh closed down
uh restaurants no longer salons and gyms
they're going back to
phase one
well
i don't know i don't know either dude
maybe they know something i don't know
yeah i've been wrong many times so i'm
gonna keep my mouth shut
just hope it's not political you hope
it's based off science and research
that's all my that's all i can hope for
you know that's not political yeah
2030 2000.20 can
eat my dick and it all started with me
blowing that asset death whistle
and i want to apologize to everybody did
well hold on did was it the aztec
whistle or was it kobe dying first i
think i blew the aztec
whistle and two weeks later the epidemic
hit
so i think kobe had already passed it
started with kobe though i think kobe
set it off
then you blow that big whistle
definitely didn't help [ __ ]
didn't help didn't help that was
probably really dumb
i gotta wait hey joe and i blame joe
because he started blowing it first
he wasn't doing it properly problem is i
did it very well daddy got his lips all
around it really i got my
lips around it i used my my covert free
lungs back then
so that's good hey you know what doesn't
help let me just say this about [ __ ]
when you're sick
i just want to let me just say this to
anybody who has a friend who said
don't do the two things number one don't
give me advice
on what to do because you're not a
doctor so whatever you do
i i get like like joseph yosef azimu
he goes you know bro do um
do listen out generalistic he goes do
large doses they say do large doses of
um
what is that let me see i'm like okay
let me write this down
dude so far it sounds like you've really
done a lot of research on that [ __ ]
thing
and everybody's got a different point of
view take all the zinc take all the
vitamin d take all the vitamin c
uh get a neti pot it'll be gone in two
days shut
the [ __ ] up none of you were doctors
then i talked to doctors and they'd go
gotta let it run its course or maybe
hydrochloroquine or maybe
inhalable steroids or or nothing or
[ __ ] maybe nothing because you can
talk
it and it it
we have friends who send me and brian
negative [ __ ] about coven
oh that's the other thing wait i gotta
say that yeah so the other thing is when
i'm sick
please don't send me articles about how
some people never come out of it and
have organ
damage for the rest of their lives and
brain damage please don't do that
mom mom don't tell me that my taste may
never come back
mom and other family members and friends
who who catastrophized i'm already
feeling like [ __ ]
i don't need you adding to my anxiety
about how this i could be the one
rare case that never gets better or gets
worse and dies
if you don't mind guys [ __ ] i don't
like negative [ __ ]
and now that i have it the people are
saying you can get it twice and they're
getting they're sending me all the stuff
about
that i don't need that either i don't
need it
this tall pen i get it that life sucks
this whole pandemic
and the whole corona stuff and just the
whole turmoil 2020
a lot of people that we associated with
have shown their true colors and i
like you know what i can't be friends
with you anymore we won't
talk once the world goes back to normal
we just
we won't talk anymore probably not
probably not fear that's a weird thing
yeah it does right yeah it does
yeah it's been a bummer it's a bummer
dude
should we go some current events jen
let's do some current events
now brandon when you want auto insurance
when you went
car insurance or home insurance what do
you do well you call
different companies and you compare
prices and you go with the lowest right
that takes forever
you go to the zebra.com they'll compare
hundreds of different companies they'll
give you the lowest rate
they do that and by the way it's
completely free
so they will find you the most
competitive price
and that's all you have to do go to this
the zebra.com
you will get you will save hundreds of
dollars
if not thousands on the best price
for your home insurance or your auto
insurance you can compare quotes side by
side from over 100 providers choose the
best for you
in 90 seconds or less plus the zebra
they will never sell your information to
spammers so you won't get all these
weird calls
oh yeah a few quick questions it's
simple it's a fast form
and they find the best rates and
coverage for your state
that's right man the best part zebra.com
it's free the zebra.com fighter that's
the h zebra z e
b r a dot com slash fighter the zebra
dot com slash
save money brandon i've been asking you
for a whoop bracelet let's go
get me something i need whoop i know now
that i'm
now i'm getting back into training i i i
literally need to start
tracking my recovery i want to track my
sleep i want to track
like how much i move during the day i
want all of it
you think your lungs are ready papa
they're gonna have to be
they're going to happen whoop will keep
track of all that stuff for them
i don't it measures like my heartbeat
100 like 100 times in a second
a second son it's the best workout
device i've ever used i started because
i want the thick boy nation
to get their asses in gear because
everyone's guessing how many calories
they're burning how many hours they're
going to sleep
should they ride long this week should
they ride short are they recovered
take all the guesswork out go to
woop.com promo code fighter
you save 15 off the subscription the
device connects to your phone
it tracks everything you do it records
from your
heart rate 100 times per second man
your strength i like it has a five day
battery life it has a five-day battery
life and i like the way it looks
it's smaller it's like literally a strap
it just looks like this giant watch
they just dropped some dope colors you
like to swim around brian you can wear
it in the ocean you wear in the pool
i'm a water i'm aquaman dude i'm a water
baby
dude we're just a couple aqua boys in
this wild world dude
yup couple aqua boys be an aqua boy
we're the whoop strap woop.com promo
code fighter you say 50
off the subscription get your mind right
take the guesswork out of it
woop.com promo code fighter all right
current events give me one sec let me
pull it up
first one one day uh hashtag r.i.p
ellen was trending and a bunch of people
thought that it was because
ella degeneres died when she didn't it
turns out that there were rumors
about her show being potentially
cancelled due to
the past couple months people just
coming out with
uh bad stories about her uh her
who was it it was somebody within her
production team actually had to come out
and say that her show isn't getting
canceled and people continue to post on
the
hashtag rip ellen trending
uh hashtag and what happened was people
started to post up
photos and videos of people that are not
ellen
but look like ellen trying to say that
her career is over
yeah i love it though but it's not like
you know there's that
the whole thing that one guy started
like give me your worst stories about
ellen
and then i know some people who that
work for are upset because she never
said anything about her pay when during
the coveted time
when other guy hosts like jimmy kimmel
jimmy fallon
paid all their employees out of their
own a lot jimmy
kimmel actually paid his employees out
of his own purse during covid because
he's a good dude
even though these dummies want to cancel
him so with with alan it's like
all these negative stories came out
about her and
her the thing that was she was in
trouble getting cancelled because her
ratings were so low
it's not because she's an [ __ ] her
ratings were really low
but i don't think they're gonna cancel
her
i mean we've we've talked about this
brian we've heard rumors of her being an
[ __ ]
forever yeah i mean you know i i don't
like rumors and i don't like
twitter and i can't stand when the
twitter mob decides that they want to
kill
somebody which is what they're about
yeah um so i you know i
i just i i live in hollywood i see the
reality and i see the
the hype and there's a big difference a
lot of times so i'm not gonna be
involved in that [ __ ]
yep me neither but and also i i you know
i've never dealt with ellen one-on-one
myself so i
i don't i don't partake in the rumors
and and these people you know that one
youtuber when our show goes
she'd even come to my dress room and say
hi it's like [ __ ] off i've never ran a
show
do you know how stressful it is around
the show and running tight on time and
you
and you're going live at three i'm i'm
sorry
you know and also don't forget ellen
degeneres is
very talented was one of my favorite
comics of all time
one of the great comics when you see her
old stuff and what got her to the dance
is really hard work and
a brilliant in mind and it might be a
complicated mind she might be a
difficult poor
person sometimes she works all day she
works all day every day
she didn't have a great childhood she's
one of the first women to come out
as gay on tv she's a [ __ ] pioneer
yeah
a little respectful a little respect
look what i'm saying
did ellen come out did that help move
the ball forward for gay
yeah and people have no idea the kind of
pressure she was under
exactly i'm old enough i don't remember
she lost her job she lost everything
it was huge they took her off she came
out said she was gay
right i'm old enough to remember when
rumors were that she was gay
and she couldn't say anything and she's
always had to live that way she was one
of the first women on
[ __ ] tv who came out and paid a price
for it so
a little respect you young fox
for a pioneer who who
did some real [ __ ] for lgbtq
and for uh for just moving the
conversation forward and everything else
so you know but it doesn't matter right
it doesn't matter i guess you were kind
of a jerk
and now they want to [ __ ] destroy you
uh you know i don't even know how real
these [ __ ] are
on this alright uh what else do i get
so this next one is really sad um
the actress nya rivera she was
originally on the show glee
on wednesday she went on a boat ride
that
she brought her four-year-old son with
her on
and a couple hours later they actually
found the boat
with the little boy inside he was
sleeping and he was fine
but the actress was nowhere to be found
and
after a couple of hours trying to find
her in the lake
they presumed that she was dead because
they couldn't find her body
they found her this morning they found a
body and they said that they were gonna
have a
press conference at the lake i think
today at two
to reveal whether it's her or not but
they're presuming it was her
and they think she was just swimming and
got caught under because
here's the thing when i first heard it i
thought she was in the ocean i'm like
well definitely shark that sucks
but she was in a lake so there's no
there's no tide in the lake
man and it's a man-made lake in
california so maybe she just couldn't
swim
you know i it's a weird situation
because
uh the little boy came out the other day
after
he was i i guess like well taking care
of and they felt like it was okay to
interview him
he said that his mom jumped off of the
boat and never came back
up she might have had a cramp she might
have
she might have fainted she might have uh
hit her head on
something man yeah you never know how
about that something
you know i have a four-year-old how
about that poor little boy being on that
boat for they found him four hours later
sleeping on the boat
see my mother's in the boat never came
back it's [ __ ] tragic
but that's your whole world so that's a
it's a
disaster it's a disaster i don't know
man
it looks like such inviting water it's
like what all of us would do you can
jump in swim around there's no
there's nothing dangerous in there and
then maybe she hit her head on the side
of the boat she slipped who the
there's people saying that like local
residents around that area
they're saying that that water is very
dangerous that's why they don't want to
go swimming in there there's like
underwater growth
trees and stuff you get entangled on
stuff like that that's right
i mean it seems like i don't know i
don't want to go
have you ever fished out their chin no
you know i'm not funny but it was weird
when i first thought i thought that was
the lake i just went to
katrina but it's not uh i've never been
to pyruvate
it's such a shame so many people have
been have been killed uh
have died from that that cast you know
committed suicide uh all kinds of stuff
uh of glee really six people
six people who are associated with that
jesus that show
six people wow that's scary yeah man
she's a proud partner yeah that's such a
shame it's very pretty
all right oh this is so weird
okay so uh i think you guys have talked
about this before
where there have always been rumors
about will smith and his wife jada
pinkett smith
being an open relationship or their
swingers
a couple of days ago uh the singer
august alcina came out
on to angela yi's show and he talked
about how he was in a relationship a
couple years ago
with jada uh pinkett smith and he was
just kind of talking about how
uh it was a really good relationship and
he loved someone
so deeply and then he went on to say
that
he talked to will smith about being in a
relationship with her
and that will smith gave him his
blessing
and a lot of people went crazy about
that
to the point where jada pickett smith
went on to her show red table talk with
her husband
where they talked about it she said that
she
and will were at the time amicably
separated
and they were gonna get a divorce and
that was the time when she started
dating the singer
and when will smith asked her what
what it was he kind of wanted her to say
that she was having an affair
and instead she used the term
entanglement which then went viral
because she refused to say that she was
in a relationship with him and
she she said she was an entanglement
which
then went viral on twitter and a bunch
of celebrities
went out and dm'd will smith shortly
after that interview went live
and uh there are text conversations
between
50 cent and will smith as well as will
smith and the comedian michael blackson
and they're just funny screenshots um
what's tough is you know if you're a
will smith fan when you watch that and
his wife goes
you know and will you and i weren't
doing good at the time and i had an
entanglement with august you can see the
pain on will smith's face man
it [ __ ] you can just tell like the
embarrassment and the pain
and then he goes well you know i'm gonna
get you back it's like what yeah
well august also is a good looking fella
yeah it's kind of a handsome dude i
looked him up and i was like huh
well all right
i don't want august i'll see that near
my girl and i don't want chris brown
near my girl there
that's hard to compete with i don't
think it's hard to compete near your
girl
either man well yeah that's true because
he's got a great personality too
and he's a handsome son of a [ __ ] how
much fun will smith is to hang out with
in
august a lot more fun than brian count
yes
yeah what else do you guys make me feel
bad
there we go and this is just a silly
video of two dads
recreating what their daughters were
doing trying to take like instagram kind
of thotty photos
i love it i absolutely love it
[Laughter]
it's so good that's so funny
i'm so mad i didn't do this me too
so funny
[Laughter]
you're making fun of me
oh my god that's so funny today that's
so good
he's so good humor humor's the best
it looks like a dad and a grandpa though
you know maybe
maybe all right gotcha we got some
serious one here
let me know what you guys think of this
footage first of all
this is austin police department and
this woman right here
i guess she was doing some there's a
protest going on in march
and then she was driving behind these
motorcycles that are just you know
making sure that nothing happens with
the march
just driving slowly so she would start
honking and yell at the officers and
then she also ran a red light
so then the officers had to you know
finally pull her over and arrest her and
this is what happened when
they were checking her
i've seen this one he he gives it the
old stiffer in her titties
can't you [ __ ] talk to her like that
get your [ __ ] hands off her
[Music]
who's the [ __ ] yelling at the police
officer trying to do his job
that's an [ __ ] but hey let me ask
people this i don't know i've never
taken cop courses how would he frisk a
woman's breast
if you're gonna hide something your
breasts which how should they do it i
don't
think you'd do that i think you have a
female do it
um that makes sense that's why she asked
for an officer that makes sense
so yeah i don't know according to their
policy though if they try to get a
female officer
and they can't get her because there's
no one there's no female option in the
area they're allowed to do
that okay that's allowed
what if she's throwing them in their
titties what are they supposed to do
you see how he's also in front of the
patrol car is trokar yeah
what we call the map mobile auto video
thing that's recording pizzas that
that's part of their policy so he had to
go
move her in front of the car so it's
recording and he has to do that kind of
grope
not groping sounds like he did his job
yeah and then
watch him as well so he did all those
things but it's just like
but that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude needs to
get punched in the face
who was [ __ ] screaming at the cop
that way it sounds like there's not a
story here
there's no story here i don't people
want to lose his job
okay of course they because he's doing
his job
the department defended him yeah
he should it should defend him what else
you got
see here
what this is frozen on like ladies
this is crazy this kid was playing
soccer i think this is a practice game
and you got hit by lightning and you can
actually see this
damn did he die chen no but he's not
doing that great so it's
um but they said he's responding to like
you know they're asking questions and
he's moving his head in his eyes so wow
let me see but i'll show you this word
russia
odds are just ridiculous for that um so
this is what the uh
update is multiple reports say that
zomborovsky went into a coma after the
strike
and suffered serious burns but reports
add signs of recovery
have been encouraging thank god jesus
christ
serious burns [ __ ] it's the last thing
you expect
play some soccer and god's like zazette
and you're like oh come
on it was quick you don't even know who
to be mad at you're like oh
no
you know what i mean it's like well
all right sometimes your boy 50 cent
i guess some rapper who's like hassling
before
there's like a video this is like way
back when this guy was like hassling 50
cent about
how come you're not listening to my
stuff i guess he was trying to like you
know get his stuff for 50 cent to listen
to
and 50's like dude this is not the way
to do it blah blah
so apparently he came back again and
then i'll show you the video here
this is the new jersey bodyguards 50
cent
you have these idiots
[Music]
chairs
throwing tables
so pretty much ended there with you left
on his with his
the girl in his truck that was pretty
much it
i feel like in that situation you should
be willing to just get out and fight the
guy
as opposed to throw a table at him i
don't know well 50 cents hits him he's
gonna be sued it's gonna
cost some way more money yeah you're
gonna get together let's throw on you
what's that and who knows if the guy has
a weapon so i'd rather just keep my
distance and throw stuff at him too
yeah well i always that's why i carry
throwing stars
because throwing stars are super quiet
and
i throw them at your [ __ ] dome and
then you got you low you are you walk
off with a bunch of stars in your dome
well that's small yep yep
all right that's what i do so brendan
you mentioned this before how
uh shia labeouf actually got chest
tattoos yep so we finally got to see it
and the artist shows
what he did exactly so check this out
yeah that's
that's that's uh like they're all real
apparently that's what the
artist is saying and everyone else it's
like this is how committed to the role
he was
see where it says everywhere across his
stomach that's his character's name
creeper
yeah the problem is that then then
you're not doing the movie anymore so
what do we do from
there no no but i guess
the tattoo represented something with
his family too his mom and stuff like
that
it's a cool tattoo good work yeah it's
really cool
all right let's see this thing i thought
was absolutely terrible i guess this
woman's a radio host
and she saw
latin american people working and their
boss was talking
to them in spanish so she started
recording herself
about like why are you speaking spanish
why are you speaking spanish she
eventually got fired from her own uh
you know studio network that she's from
but i'll play this video for you
you speaking
okay but it is america it is america you
should be speaking english
jesus you should be speaking english
they work for the state you should be
speaking english
what do you work for oh so these people
is english it doesn't matter it's still
english it's english english english
is anybody here illegal oh wow are these
guys illegal
no any what's the name of this company
look at this it's america
speak english speak english
so he's this is a foreman working for
this company morons
and he's speaking he's speaking spanish
to these guys so your tax doll is up
here in new hampshire
that's what's going on here up here in
new hampshire
all up in new hampshire look at this
language so this guy was defending other
guys as well
right the brown man from this white
woman
who's practiced um white privilege
anyways she's a terrible person she got
fired from her job yeah shut up that is
he
it listen the camera that's not the
fight to have sucks
yeah uh yeah that's
the last one is a very sad one and i
didn't want to end on a side note
all these have been sad but what else
you got you mentioned this
zooming so assuming so it is uh you
mentioned that's on below the belt as
well but
his wife terrible boy what happened
she passed away yeah who's who's wife
john travolta kelly preston they've been
together oh i know i worked with kelly
yeah
no way she was so awesome what happened
breast cancer
oh [ __ ] man kelly was in here
so pretty she was so gorgeous and we did
she was so cool i spent a week with her
man
she when i did fat actress when was fat
actress somebody look it up
but [ __ ] 2005 i don't know she's so
pretty she's gorgeous damn she died of
breast cancer
she was a really hot girl in twins with
arnold schwarzenegger's girl twins
she was so gorgeous dude and a good
actress and a good person
she died of [ __ ] breast cancer i
didn't know she was sick
right actress is 2005
well i'm sorry that she's passed away
oh well i know the good news
well guys it was a monday we came
we did it we did our best we did our
best buddy
hopefully b let's get in there take
those tests get those negative test
results buddy so we can be in studio
i'm all about it buddy i promise all
right pal all about it
all right kids well thank you for
listening thank you for listening
a little bit uh i dropped all new think
boy merch summer mitch
merch just dropped dickboy.com get you
some thinkies
yeah that's it man all right kids this
stuff on kid
we're out